Just because you're short on cash, doesn't mean you can't see the world.
You will need: Patience to sniff out the best deals,...
...willingness to rough it,...
...and the ability to be flexible.
Optional: A budget travel guidebook.
Step 1: Use travel consolidators on and offline.
They snatch up empty airline seats and unsold cruise cabins...
...and resell them at a great discount.
Sign up to receive information on last-minute deals.
Call hotels directly to see if you can negotiate a cheaper rate.
Step 2: Consider youth hostels,...
...especially in the more expensive cities around the world.
You'll sacrifice privacy, but you'll save a bundle.
If you live in a popular travel destination, consider swapping homes with someone.
Step 3: Rely on street food vendors for most of your meals.
If you like to eat out, make lunch your daily restaurant treat instead of dinner.
Step 4: Check out student rates on bus and rail passes.
Be a "voluntourist" in a country you'd like to visit.
You'll get to explore a new culture while helping out the locals...
...and maybe even wrangle some school credit for the experience.
Step 5: Be flexible.
Monday and Thursday departures are generally cheaper than weekend fares,...
...and save a bundle by flying into a less popular city,...
...and then catching a train or driving to your desired destination.
Step 6: Vacation in the off-season,...
...when prices are cheaper and you don't have to fight the crowds.
Did you know? According to one survey,...
...French air travelers rate safety as less important than getting a cheap seat.